[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online they would like to know what you
thought of mommy's performance today
pink and her five-year-old willow
enjoyed a mother-daughter date out at
the movies while Nick and Vanessa Lachey
soaked up the Sun on a family vacation
alongside their kids Camden and Brooklyn
I'm very excited another famous family
having fun
The Smiths here's will and Jaden taking
some silly selfies after the 18 year old
chopped his dreadlocks off for his new
film life in a year
Khloe Kardashian shared this sweet snap
to Instagram loving on her man Tristan
Thompson the 32 year old opened up about
her beau in the new issue of ES magazine
where she got candid about the idea of
marriage she gushed quote yes I would
accept if he proposed I've never been in
this type of love I just want to live my
life and be happy
meanwhile stranger things star Shannon
purser opened up on Twitter about having
anxiety when it comes to her sexuality
the 19 year old actress wrote quote
getting comfortable with your sexuality
is a process it's going to be okay I
wish I had known that sooner